being able to have a choice as a parent
you know I can't explain Katrina
devastated New Orleans few would have
predicted the kind of school choice
revolution that's taking place today but
sometimes things get so bad that radical
change is possible even in a town
dominated by Democrats who normally side
with public teachers unions rather than
supporting things like charter schools
and voucher programs ten years ago
Orleans Parish Public Schools were some
of the worst in the country dr. Carolyn
Trudeau developed an intimate
understanding of the problem while
working with troubled public school
students I'm a psychologist and we had
an I had a medical clinic and we saw so
many kids that would come in from the
public school system that was totally
disturbed about relating to their
teachers having a treatment plan having
an educational plan the counselors and
myself we would take hours and hours of
evaluating children that was reported
from the public school system as if they
you know had a learning disability and a
lot of times through our findings they
didn't they just needed another
environment they needed more love and
will care with the goal of creating a
more supportive learning environment for
poor kids in New Orleans
dr. Trudeau started her own private
school the conquering word Christian
Academy the small school was attractive
to many parents but persuading parents
with limited resources to come out of
pocket for tuition proved to be a
significant challenge you know we were
actually doing all that we could you
know to get parents of low-income to
believe that they could afford tuition
just to rescue their kids in 2005
parents in New Orleans had precious few
educational options and then Katrina
shut down the public school system and
forced nearly a million people to leave
their homes
when toriana Trudeau and her family
finally returned to New Orleans she had
some difficult decisions to make yeah
they were 2 and 3 when the hurricane hit
so we were out there in Baton Rouge and
the schools that they went to embed in
her school they were pretty feel pretty
good compared to here and like I said
when I came home I dreaded coming home I
didn't want to put my children into a
public school here in New Orleans but of
course they had to go so um the people
just weren't inviting soon as you walk
into the Lord as a table with security
guards set up and if you don't have your
ID you can't get through you can't even
go to the office and acts a simple
question
they were doing really well but when I
found out the school was a failing
school then actually how well were they
really doing Shree Medlock of the black
Alliance for educational options works
to increase choice for parents like
toriana
our focus is not necessarily private or
public or home school it's all the
options we want to make sure all the
parents that our parents are equipped
with all of the necessary information so
that they can go out and make quality
choices for their children's education
and in the wake of Katrina the efforts
of reformers like Shree began to pay off
the state of Louisiana took over most
Orleans Parish Public Schools and has
been converting them to charter schools
ever since next year more than 70% of
public school students in New Orleans
will attend charter schools where test
scores are on the rise and in 2008 the
state implemented a voucher program to
allow children in failing public schools
to attend private ones this upcoming
school year we have
over 2,000 applicants we really only
have money for about 1700 when I found
out about the voucher program I went
down in and I jumped on it as soon as
possible because like I said I didn't
want to send them back to that I was
Asian I was even thinking about
homeschooling them if I had to every
person who comes in said the kids cannot
wait to get up in the morning to get
dressed to come to school I love it I
love it my children love it you know we
all like a family here pretty much as
surprising as it may sound
New Orleans is now the most market-based
school district in the country and the
fact that the city has a voucher system
is astonishing to many please understand
that we're in Louisiana and two years
ago three almost three years ago in 2008
when the scholarship program was
approved and voted to actually go into
law we it was just everybody was totally
in shock across the country a lot of
African American legislators always
stand in the way of making this happen
for their communities they and I believe
it's because I just don't understand
last year we had a black elected or we
call our annual seminar which is we
bring together black elected officials
from across the country together and we
had over a hundred to attend and this is
you know black Democrats in all over the
country come together and talk about
education reform we started this thing
five years ago two people were in the
room so it was that the movement has
shifted and it is changing and it's
growing and nobody appreciates the
school choice revolution in New Orleans
more than the parents of children whose
futures all of a sudden looked much
brighter than they did just a few years
ago last year we had a rally at the
governor's mansion 498 parents took off
their jobs got on a bus and took the
whole day off just to go and meet with
their legislators and say thank you to
people that voted for this program I had
to go to public schools so to give them
the opportunity to go to a private
school for a better education just to go
on with life I mean it was it was a
blessing thank goodness that the
faith-based community is stepping up and
being recognized once and for all that
we can change our communities I think
that right now the synergy is just an
incredible here we have a lot of
opportunity here and parents are seeing
the benefit of that and they're really
excited about it